[Music]
so in November you announced your
retirement this will be my last season
as a full-time driver when you look back
do you feel like you accomplished
everything that you hope to in this
Court
no absolutely not if you went through
every driver in the Cup Series what any
drivers say I accomplished everything I
hope for I don't know if they did then I
wonder what they're like what their idea
of success was or you know I don't know
I'd say she should hire like I think I
should always fall short
you know the frustrating thing is at the
end of my second year I finally got to
the point where it was like fall flying
the top 12 was really normal different
crew chief changes and things like that
you know it just you know had to keep
restarting so yeah so that's a little
frustrating and that's part of you know
part of leaving it's like I don't know
what the answer is so you have happiness
yeah and you have new love yeah tell me
about Aaron look he's such an elite
athlete himself that now the table has
turned and he gets to watch you compete
yes that like I came into the bus after
being in my suit for media day and I was
like oh my god he's never seen me in my
suit before this makes you funny she
just kept going like let me see those
things and he's like looking he's like
Tara I'm like what what's that
I felt like slightly uncomfortable I Q I
look weird but it's just neat that he
can see what I do really firsthand
because there's not much of it left
so when Sundy ends how do you envision
that farewell playing out for you I
don't think that getting out of the car
part is gonna be the hard part I think
the hard part is gonna be getting in the
car I think it's gonna be you know
family right there and
look you know my dad he's emotional he's
gonna be a disaster
you're so competitive are you gonna miss
it I mean probably I don't really know
what it's like to not race so we'll see
[Music]